[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum good morning good
afternoon good evening
whatever you are whenever you are
listening to this podcast i just want to
say thanks for listening thanks for
tuning in each week um and supporting
the podcast
really means a lot and i know there's so
many podcasts out there and uh if you're
new here and if you're here for doug
jones who's a brilliant actor
um and a great guest which you're gonna
love uh hopefully you'll stick around
and listen to other guests and subscribe
um you can follow us uh where can they
follow us ryan at inside if you pod on
twitter and have inside of your podcasts
on instagram and facebook there you go
that's right it's right there it's very
easy and you can watch us on youtube he
could watch the videos like them and
what's really important is if you write
a review that really means a lot helps
so much
quickly i want to just mention a a
rescue that i'm part of it's called the
animal rescue mission
they rescue rehab and find forever homes
for abused and neglected animals and uh
my good friend shira runs that and she's
a beautiful soul and they really help a
lot of animals go to
www.theanimalrescuemission.org
to donate that would be nice of you
also if you uh
want to join patreon patreon support the
podcast in many ways go to patreon.com
inside of you and i'll send you a
message after you join and uh there's
lots of tiers and there's a top tier
where i send packages to you and the
youtube with me live where you ask me
questions and there's just it's a bunch
of fun go to patreon.com inside of you
also if you want any cool merch go to
the inside of you online store tons of
smallville stuff tons of inside of you
stuff go to the inside of you online
store uh that's always rocking we got a
lot of new stuff
i'll be in raleigh this weekend i'm
doing a smallville nights with tom
welling and signing autographs so get
there it's for galaxycon
this coming weekend and i'll be in
boston august 12th weekend with tom
doing the smallville nights and all that
stuff and signing autographs uh today's
guest is
i just loved having him on ryan he was
um
you know
so open about his upbringing his life
acting working with prosthetics
um
working in huge movies huge movies and
how he doesn't get um what's the word
claustrophobic
and and some of those you know like um
what's the movie shape of a shape of
water and i'm like how do you do that i
can't i try to they try to do a mask on
me once like a mold of my head and i
freaked out i freaked out is it there no
it's not that one but it was another one
this is the one that ryan was looking at
it's a that's a helmet but this was a
mold of my head
and uh by the way it's crazy uh we'll
get right into doug jones after this but
i
i
i was having some anxiety bad anxiety
and i got on these meds
they were they did not work it tells you
that look not all meds are gonna work
for anxiety it
my anxiety was through the roof after
this it negative thoughts i felt
horrible i couldn't be around people i
had to get off them it was terrible
so just know that if you know your
psychiatrist or whatever gets you on
meds not all of them work so it's a
trial and error it's sort of like you
know you test one and if you have major
problems you call your guy right away
and say look i'm not feeling well and
boy
uh my friends we had a 50th gathering
for my birthday at buca de beppo
and they hooked it up in the back room
and
on the way there i got there and i
thought i was going to pass out and i
almost just walked away and the whole
night was horrible
i told everybody i was having horrible
anxiety and i i played it off
but but i was miserable i was certainly
miserable
and uh just to let you know that was a
side effect and it happens
and uh i'm doing much better now but it
was rough ryan
i'm sorry for interrupting that with my
phone but that's okay
i just kept going i'm glad you're okay
yeah i text you and i told you how
shitty i was feeling it was it was
overwhelming to the point where i'm like
i can't do this podcast anymore i can't
do i can't do this i can't i just want
to move i want to get away from it all i
can't be around anything i can i was
like whoa whoa whoa buddy
rewind
and then there's better help
betterhelp.com
great segway you know uh we can get into
that later but look let's uh let's do
this right now i just wanted to let you
know how i was feeling and i'll let you
know what's going on with me and the
podcast and animal rescue mission and
all that stuff i hope you beard with me
and let's just get into it thanks for
all the support let's get inside of doug
jones it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
first of all uh thank you for being here
thank you for having what a treat we've
met a couple times yes at conventions
and things like that and i was always
like
this guy is extraordinary
yeah i always felt like you were
extraordinary you're an extraordinary
individual you have an extraordinary
career because it probably didn't go the
way you thought it would go yeah it went
in a very a very different way but uh
wait you said you were nervous to be on
my show that's weird i'm always nervous
to interview guests are you really oh
yeah i always do i'm just like i don't
know how it's going to go you appear so
comfortable
your show does a deep dive that uh that
is terrifying really yes well we you
know it's it i think inadvertent is the
word i i don't i don't try to get like
inside i mean i do well that's the name
of the show i do a very intimate title
by the way but it is right i know you
know what's funny is i had these
sweatshirts and uh that my producer made
and he didn't put with michael rosenbaum
it just says inside of you right so at a
starbucks
people like what the [ __ ] is he doing
yeah so i mean look the point is to have
a real conversation people don't want to
hear conversations with actors about
like you know all the fluff or going
down the interview oh you were in john
daisy dan what was that like worst
interview ever but we but i talk about
that it's like you know i go to wiki i
go to all these things but like really
it's about your journey and it's about
who you are and that's that's all it is
i mean it's like
i've had guests that don't talk very
much we've had guests really talk a lot
which is great right are you a talker
more than i should be yeah
because when i get started on a story
it's like you know that's a train that
it's hard to stop so i'm sorry
careful what you opened up no no i like
it how many credits would you say you
have because i know i recently saw you
in what we do in the shadows that was
the most recent which because i know
you're in star trek discovery
you know you've done hellboy and
i mean there's shape of water and uh
mimic and
hocus pocus and i mean the list goes on
pan's labyrinth and you've done so many
things
that
i mean it's you have you have an
illustrious career well and i i thank
you but i wouldn't say it's because i'm
good it's because i'm old and i've had
time to rack them up that's it that's it
that's it i i beg to differ my friend i
mean i've heard i think what you have
done is
much harder than your typical actor
well harder i don't know you know it's
uh hard and difficult is all those are
relative terms really aren't they i
think aren't they because i guess so any
actor that takes on a character is going
to take it has their difficulties in
finding that character and making them
come through their their being whatever
it is so whether it's a guy in a t-shirt
and jeans with heavy emotional trauma
that's what you're playing or whether
it's a creature in rubber bits from head
to toe and you're crawling on all fours
that's they got its difficulties
different types it just seems like when
you're doing a we'll get into this but
like it seems like when you're doing a
creature or uh you know some
character in a movie and you have
prosthetics on you have all these things
on it feels like especially if you don't
speak a lot it you have to
[Music]
it's your body that expresses all these
things your your emotions and things and
things have to come out and it just
seems like that's harder you know if you
have lines you could say some lines and
people go oh that's sad that his brother
died
but when you have to mode all this [ __ ]
right i mean doesn't that don't you have
to work harder you think
yeah sure
well
you have to work different maybe not
harder um
i believe that dialogue comes in uh
visuals and verbal right right and we
all we all speak it every day but we're
just not as we're not so aware of the
visuals uh that we're giving so when you
are playing a creature that that has no
written verbal dialogue lines uh you
have tons of dialogue that is visual to
get a point across to get an emotion
across to get a relationship across uh
the shape of water is probably the most
the most near and dear to me as far as
the non-verbal characters that i've
played right the amphibian man in that
didn't speak a word he was an animal
from the wild and he's falling in love
with a mute woman so she didn't speak
either so the two of us had to find good
completely on-screen language with each
other that the audience would buy right
yeah so so i i've had tons of dialogue
over the years whether it's whether it's
spoken or shown right but you know we'll
get into this again shape of water but i
know that
uh the director i always messed his name
up
guillermo de toro
i've heard everything over there
what's it like working with guillermo
what's up with guermotaro
um
but he said something to you in the
shape of water before you started
filming yes i saw an interview with you
oh and he said something to you which
sounds pretty frightening but it's like
what did he say to you
you would be the romantic leading man of
this movie is that the way you're
talking about yep exactly and right and
i'm thinking like you just told me about
this being a fish person so that's gonna
be there's a tall order right you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah but but then
but the next breath i thought to myself
guillermo del toro is the one director
who can pull this off as far as like
writing it and guiding me through it and
he sure did but didn't he say something
like you're playing an animal and uh but
you have to be we have to love you yeah
yeah oh yeah i
have to
the audience has to has to buy that this
woman is falling in love with me yeah so
i have to have a romance to me i have to
have a sexy look the the look of the
amphibian man went through a year of
tweaks and changes and color changes and
shape changes the ass and the lips were
the two areas on the fish man that were
the most retooled over the over really
they wanted you to have a nice ass oh
gosh yeah and i'll tell you what uh i
knew that they pulled that off uh it was
glued onto me by the way it wasn't my
ass i had to give it back every day but
but
but i knew i knew the ass was working
when we're all sitting on our set chairs
you know between shot setups and i stand
up to walk away and octavia spencer says
that's when i knew that we pulled it off
really yeah that was it how many times
did you have to
i'm sorry i'm sorry i know right oh yeah
damn right right right amphibious he's
given several interviews since then uh
addressing that yeah oh yeah how long
did you film that movie by the way
we were doing about three months i think
three months three months but you how
many times did you have to get in that
costume to test it out the process
beforehand oh yeah uh in any of the
roles i've done in heavy prosthetics you
do several fittings ahead of time like
you know maybe like you start doing that
months beforehand so i thought i lost
count you know and it might be one piece
at a time like we thought we need to
come in this neck piece isn't working
can you come in we have to fit this one
bit on
uh so the full body head to head to toe
test it comes later closer to the
production right
there the academy uh uh museum that's
the that opened up in the last year has
a big display of the amphibian man from
it's a full size it is my actual suit
one of my actual suits from the movie
that has been now reconstructed onto a
dummy right uh not this dummy the
different dummy and um and it's in a
it's in a glass case in the museum with
a a picture and a plaque down there that
describes what you're looking at with a
photo of me in one of my early fittings
and it was kind of me without the head
on kind of doing a pose to to test out
how the arms and legs move
the fittings were uh were so particular
and so precise that they
because because any anywhere any
direction you move or
bend there shouldn't be a wrinkle that
says uh it's a rubber suit right right
so that's what they have to like tweak
and fine-tune and so so getting it on is
like it takes three grown adults to go
30 minutes to get that ass yeah to get
to get the suit on then you have glued
on parts too so like the difference
between a suit and a makeup is a suit
you slip on zip up the back and make up
you either glue or paint on the skin
right so uh that was a combination of
both so i see this i feel like such a
what's the right turn to use
is i can't say
[ __ ] no you can't say that anymore
i can't i can't say i feel wussy use the
w how about it yeah
yeah yeah that's what i could say that
well here i'm suggesting you call
yourself away that's terrible i wouldn't
say that well i feel like that because
you know i
like i had to shave my head for seven
years and uh it was and that gets
tiresome two and a half hours in the
makeup trailer and every day and you
know they had to put a lot of makeup on
me and then i just turned down a roll
because i didn't want to wear a
prosthetic for
because i just i i i'm claustrophobic
i'm all these things sure but i feel
like such a wuss because
do you even
get scared do you get claustrophobic
nothing you've never been claustrophobic
in a costume
all right but that's it but you can't
control winner when it doesn't happen
you know winner uh
i did a movie called the time machine it
was
a remake of the 1960 one uh hg wells yes
uh and it was directed by simon wells
who was uh
hg's like grandson i think
um
we had a legacy you know on set with us
it was great but i played one of the uh
one of the uh underground dweller um
what are we called the uh
uh help me
no ah think about it the
more morlocks more likes i was one of
the more morlocks yes like ryan would
know what the [ __ ] that is i know i'm
tapping ryan what is it help me more
more locks more locks we got it
yeah google duty
inside of you is brought to you by
freedom grooming uh this is something i
wish i had when i was bald and said to
all the bald people out there
this is for you talk about a product
that is so wonderful that it avoids
nicks and cuts and
irritation or ingrown hairs freedom
grooming has created the flex series
electric shaver which is uniquely
designed to flex and contour the curve
of your head for a smoother faster and
safer shape without the risk of nick's
cuts irritation or ingrowns get the
smoothest shave of your life flexible
blades contour to the shape of your head
for a baby smooth shave every time shave
fifty percent more hair in a single
stroke compared to traditional razors
expect shave times of two to three
minutes not ten to fifteen and never cut
yourself shaving again the flex series
safeguard technology means no nicks no
ingrown hairs no problems
and the flex series waterproof design
means you can shave in the shower with
or without shaving cream shave wet or
shave dry it's pretty incredible it's an
incredible product uh like i said i mean
i look i i was bald for seven years and
i remember cutting them cutting my head
when they shaved my head every day i
can't say the razor i used but it used
to nicks and ingrowns and blood and i
just
i needed something like this this is a
fantastic product the flex series
electric shaver since even the sharpest
blades dull with use freedom created the
close shave plan with the close shave
plan you'll never run out of fresh sharp
blades delivered to your door every six
weeks with free shipping all active
close shave plan members are upgraded to
a lifetime warranty and it's completely
customizable adjust skip or cancel your
plan anytime and freedom grooming has
over ten thousand five star reviews
so thank you for being a loyal listener
and uh we're partnering with freedom to
give you an exclusive 20 off when you go
to
slash
freedomgrooming.com
that's freedomgrooming.com
inside you're gonna need this product
folks
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify we love our shopify uh i have a
shopify account it's where all my
merches for the inside of you online
store i do not know what i would do
without shopify i would not have a store
they make it so easy
so simple uh
it's just an amazing amazing thing
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big
businesses so upstarts startups and
established businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed you know what's great about
shopify is ryan i know how products are
doing
i know how they're selling i know how
much i'm making this month i know what
the dud products are it gives me just an
accurate up-to-date look at how things
are going on my store
i really don't know what i would do
without shopify um
like this podcast we started selling uh
you know a t-shirt
and now i have 30 40 items and i can i
could even grow i mean we have so many
items to sell thanks to shopify uh
we're selling a lot
uh like mine shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale to full scale
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting of conversion rates profit
margins and beyond it's more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
slash inside right now shopify.com
inside
anyway uh to why why did i i seen this
because you were warned that we were
talking about is there ever an instance
that you got claustrophobic and you said
it comes and goes okay so there were a
ton of morlocks in the movie i was the
only actor the rest of them were all
stuntmen
and uh so
um and a lot of these you know
there were two types of morlocks the
skinny ones that were shooting darts at
the eloy people and then the big big
hunter morlux that came up and would
grab them once they were spiked in the
neck they would grab them and take them
back down underground well the big the
big hunter morlocks were these uh i mean
these stunt stunt guys who had you know
dived out of four-story buildings that
are on fire they've crashed cars over
cliffs and now they put this thing on
them and you didn't every every so often
like during the early days they were
kind of like testing these guys and they
had me come in to kind of like because i
was the only one who had done this for
you know decades before right and they
were like you know can you just kind of
help guide everybody because there's
some first-timers here and to see a big
guy like freak out and go like get this
off me get this off me
you just can't control it you can't
control when it's going to happen and
then you can calm him down well it
doesn't make you a wussy it doesn't make
you listen it doesn't okay thank you no
no it really doesn't because uh because
there's all kinds of psychological
backstory that leads you to that moment
where you're having a freak out because
there's something around your face you
and you you you don't have time to delve
into that i think let's have a therapy
session before we do this movie
so you know so some some of the guys
were like you know this has been great
but i'm out of here you know really they
quit oh yeah okay cannot do it yeah
you've seen people get up and leave
that particular production just because
there were so many uh but other
otherwise they you can uh you you vet
your your candidates ahead of time
before you bring them in you know you'll
know
you find guys who have who or ladies who
have worn rubber bits before and are
used to it and comfortable with it they
tried putting it they had to put a
rubber mold over my head i had a full
face mold
you had you've done many of these like
a life cast when they're yeah yeah doing
compression
of you uh-huh and you know it's like
painting that blue stuff on you and then
alginate yeah yes and then it gets hard
it hardens and then they plaster over
that and about eight minutes then i go
yeah
not through your mouth you guys guys um
how long how long do you have left uh we
have about ten more minutes of this and
then we have to do this and i go i don't
think i could do this i don't think i
could do it and then go well just try to
breathe try to breathe and
they got me through it and i was just
i'm getting nervous like even talking
about it just talking about
what is that do you think there's some
psychological thing connected like you
said maybe to that maybe something some
trauma i had that i can't be in a or or
it could be also a fear of death uh uh
because um you know when you think of
being buried after you're dead your body
going under and if you're not okay with
like where your soul will go after
you're dead maybe that's a terrifying
thought you know and so here you are
being encased like a you mummified
really
in that moment and you have to trust the
people working on you will take it off
that's what i've learned is that you
have to trust it's coming off at the end
of the day or it's coming off in a few
20 minutes when this life cast is done i
also find that it helps if someone just
touches my hand every so often let them
remind me that they're there right
even when i'm in a dentist chair right
getting worked on like
the pain and anguish of having things
drilled and filled and ripped out and
replaced or whatever they do
oh the older i get my my teeth are
rotting out of my head so i've been i've
been in a lot
i find myself if i hold my own hands in
the dental chair i'm i do much better
just holding my own hands that way i can
i can kind of caress my my own did you
ever explain to them when they're
looking at you going like this or you
just said yeah it helps me it just it
just helps me so you're more fearful of
the dentist chair oh yeah than you are
getting hours of prosthetics on oh yeah
holy [ __ ] but the prosthetic process
probably has helped me with my dental
fears uh yeah you know because i i
i avoided the dental chair for a long
time
it's always that moment where i'm like
dentist is fine this is fine and then
all of a sudden that nerve you hit a
nerve and it's just like
ah
exactly right yeah just the worst and
then you're then you're
yeah i i know what you mean let's go
back because i love that you're from
indiana originally yeah do you know i'm
from indiana uh no i grew up in a small
town called newberg near evansville
indiana oh down south yeah yeah and
you're in evan you're in indianapolis
right right yeah and uh so you grew up
in indiana what was it like growing up
little doug jones what were you into
what were you getting into in indiana
flashlight tag
remember that catching fireflies
catching flowers august
dusk oh the summer when the summertime
it came and the warm humid and the
fireflies were out they were so easy to
catch too yeah poop
put them in a jar jar flashlight yeah
they didn't last forever unfortunately
did they no they didn't
but um
yeah but like yeah no i'm from that era
of going outside and playing until the
street lights come on uh you know kind
of thing where you didn't have no one we
didn't have cell phones we didn't know
what that even was right um you know you
you weren't you weren't looking at a
screen all day you were outside playing
in the mud and
you know in your parents let's just i
walked to school by myself yeah me too
yeah you know
were you popular kid no uh yeah yes and
no i'm gonna say uh uh i was a
a strange kid
uh but now what what's the definition of
strange again it's all relative right we
all feel like we're streaming because
everybody's like weird is good
right now it is well back then it wasn't
easy
right in this in the 60s 70s it was not
quite my mom says i'm special right
right well
it's not gonna help you right now
still gonna kick your ass
that's what's good exactly yeah yeah so
being a very tall skinny kid uh um i
i was made fun of quite a bit uh because
kids are cruel to each other we you know
you you pick the weak spot and you go
for it
and what got you what was the weak spot
my long skinny neck my neck and
it was
walking into a room and having people
just look at me because i'm taller than
everyone else i'm skinnier than everyone
else
and and then was nervous about that so
my behavior became kind of awkward like
and so i would make funny faces and
gesture with my hands to uh to try to
get over over that lump of of nerves and
that made me kind of a who was this
freak
so but thank heaven i was able to hone
that into a sense of humor that where i
could control when and why they were
laughing at me right so i think that's
where i know you'll find a lot of
comedians especially have this
background where they got funny to
overcome something right in their life
i'm included in that but you were picked
on you were picked up pic picked on to a
point i i was never beaten up never
beaten up no uh but but but verbally
made fun up to the point where my
self-image was completely skewed how old
were you um this is this is thought this
is from this is from kindergarten
through you know the to the beginning of
high school wow
in high school i kind of came into
myself and and uh was a little bit more
um
again that sense of humor had developed
and that stage presence in the
the plays and the drama department uh
what got you into that
finding finding applause and and
reaction from an audience that i wasn't
getting in my personal life if that
makes sense
certainly yeah any actor can agree with
that yeah
um you're not being accepted in this
world but maybe it will be accepted in
this world right because when uh
in a in a social setting my again being
called an ostrich uh and i didn't know
what an ostrich was i had to look it up
and when i saw a picture of an ostrich
for the first time oh that's not a
compliment at all she's a human
yeah no so uh my long skinny neck and
getting pictures taken from the side uh
you know for profile i had a very weak
chin what you're looking at is a chin
implant i'm gonna be honest with you
right now i have a half inch chin
implant really i got a
1992 uh and i i said i will never regret
that decision to have to have my my chin
enhancement it looks fantastic i would
never know it's not big now what was it
like before so before it was like i had
a bottom lip and an adam's apple and not
much between really yeah so do you have
pictures of that still oh bad well
they're on paper thank heaven digital it
wasn't around then so they're not
they're not out there in the cloud
anywhere and this was 19
did you get it fixed
in 1992 90 i had just finished batman
returns and i took some of that salary
and and uh put it into my channel how
much was it to get your chin redone i
got a good deal i'm gonna guess 10 grand
no no not even close uh dr akamazo was
his name i don't remember that um
the sweetheart of a guy uh referred to
me by a nurse friend who had worked with
him and had observed his operations and
she said oh he's the guy you want
uh so i went and met with him and i told
him like i'm kind of on a budget
and he said well you know i can i can
piggyback you on someone who's getting a
facelift right before you so uh so the
the room was paid for but it was just
his time and the the material so i got
it all done for 1500.
one time well now it would be ten
thousand now it would be ten thousand
yeah yeah because it was so long ago
yeah
with inflation did you notice
immediately you were happy you were like
oh my like how soon after you never
never once regretted did you cry oh yeah
when i first when they took the bandages
came off it was like that's what i've
been praying for
really yeah he cried in front of the
doctor probably a little looked here
when he wasn't a heave cry it was more
of a
okay it's working thank you thank you
back but uh but mind you uh i i
i wouldn't say suggest
going under the knife to make yourself
feel better under every circumstance
this was something that had been nagging
me since i was a kid and every time i
had a photo taken from a profile or my
or if i was on camera from from the side
i would jut my jaw out to kind of
compensate for my lacking chin and that
that altered how i reacted how i how i
met the world every day with my chin
jutted out artificially because i didn't
want anyone to see that i had a weak
chin you would literally do that oh yeah
oh gosh yeah
yeah
so uh so it was affecting my uh
as an actor it's like i didn't want to
have that nagging me every day right so
i just kind of it's kind of tucking your
shirt in you know i i looked at it like
well it's if my shirt doesn't look good
out i'll just give it a little tuck so i
kind of did that with my chin
did a little thing and that's the i've
never gone back for more you know like
oh i want to get everything done now
like you know those people you know oh
you're awesome you start you can't stop
right when you see those people so uh
i've never never become that but
but uh
i love i love you know i i was thinking
i was thinking uh i have a deviated
septum in my my right nostrils don't
have my nose strips i want no strips
overnight to breathe but eventually i
want to get it fixed and the doctor's
like you know you have this thing where
your nose kind of like see how it kind
of smushes does your nose is there much
cartilage in there not a lot of
cartilage because mine's kind of firmer
than that see mine's not firm so he's
like while we're doing that i'd like to
put a little piece in there which you
wouldn't even notice it just raises it
so your notice doesn't collapse as you
get older
there's a thought so it doesn't get you
know because you have one of those noses
that could just like you could end up
going down where you were like
meeting your upper lip yeah and you're
like and i'm like but my friend's like
no you're not getting a nose job i'm
like i'm not getting i have a deviated
acceptance yeah everybody says everyone
says that yeah no but i'm serious they
have a deviantart right well you're not
gonna michael jackson it you're gonna
you're talking yeah all right so that's
okay you're telling me i'll be fine i
should do it you'll be fine you should
do it
and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts
that's different well it's completely
different
just uh being
depleted depleted of energy overworked
overworked not making enough time for
yourself yep have you guys felt burnt
out i i know i have i constantly feel
burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yep
listen to better help
um
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself i don't know how
many times i say this on the podcast be
good to you be good to yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
um i know that i get so in my head
that i sometimes don't know what to do
next i don't i'm overwhelmed with life
i'm overwhelmed and i just tend to go
back in the bedroom and just fall on my
bed and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ]
if i could say that i don't think better
help it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but um
talking to a therapist talking to
someone
someone who's objective someone who can
you know who listen to you who's a
professional it helps it really truly
helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take
take uh all the patrons and all the
people around the world that use better
help yeah take their word for it yeah um
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy i can
tell you that especially living out here
in california you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours and our
listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help better h-e-l-p
dot com slash
inside
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
do you have you ever had a deviated
septum no my nose has been it is what it
is you have a good nose thank you you're
both blessed are you a snorer
no apparently not why do all snorers
fall asleep first you ever notice that
not fair is it it's not fair yeah and
mrs lori will not want me see this is
what scares me about your show this is
laurie snores this deep dive i've talked
about my fake chin which i've never
mentioned in public
and it's a beautiful thing right and now
i'm talking about mrs laurie snoring
this is she
she's going to hate this
show gonna hate this show
ah dear sakes yeah were your uh were
your parents very what were they like
did you have very uh
supportive parents were they like doug i
love you i'm proud of you were you were
they like that or they were how were
they yeah
they weren't you know the tone of my
voice like yeah mostly uh uh you know
dad was very stressed he he passed away
at age 50 i was only 18. so it has been
gone a long time since 1979
you were 18. yeah about i was just about
a month from turning 19. were you guys
close
uh getting closer finally you know
because those those angsty teenage years
had i was just at the kind of the end of
that and i've gone away to college for
my freshman year at ball state
university in indiana all state they
said ball state don't get me i won't
take you off your train of thought but
they i remember that wasn't there a
david letterman
scholarship that if you had a c you
would qualify right he did it
right
right and i actually went back to ball
state later uh in more recent years i i
have the doug jones endowed scholarship
fund for the theater dance department
wow and i wanted to do the same thing
because i was not a a straight a student
there was a neurologist and so i wanted
to make it accessible to creative kids
who are really talented who may not be
academically
on the same you know high high high
right so at the time though but their
their their admission standards had gone
up so much that that wasn't possible
anymore right unfortunately so i'm not
sure what what that what the letterman
scholarships
anyway
uh but what how okay we ha see your
father your father father father okay
see i i listened right
you were 18 your father's 50 and he
passes away right now he was getting
closer and i was at the end of my
freshman year of college i'd been so
i've been away living in a dorm and
living away from home under the parent's
thumb for you know that that that whole
two semesters or whatever
and uh and realizing like oh my parents
aren't quite as dumb as i thought they
were right you know how you do when you
finally get away from home and they were
just looking out for my best interest
and wow they really do love me and then
he dies and it was so wait i felt kind
of unexpectedly oh yeah it was a sudden
heart attack so it was like just a phone
call in my dorm room one night guess
what dad dad's dead
oh
man yeah you'll never forget that no
gosh no harrowing at that age
because you think at that when you're 18
everyone's going to live forever you
know in your mind yeah
uh it's just scared to get that call and
we we all could get that call like that
any minute with anybody you never know
it's just so unpredictable yeah go ahead
yeah yeah that's the unfortunate uh
reality of the human experiences it's
it's temporary right right the yeah the
fleshy part of us anyway and
so uh but dad was a self-made fellow uh
he
um he was very type a personality very
high stress high strung the heart attack
didn't surprise me once i figured it all
out you know a horrible diet in the 70s
workaholic workaholic didn't know about
cholesterol back then uh
and uh
and he was uh you know uh quick to
temper and he was a very high strung but
you know as a
uh he started his own business a
consulting firm
he also was in local politics
as a state legislator in our state
government a lot to look up to right
like yeah he was quite a public figure
locally yeah for sure and he also
started a church in our living room uh
this is back in this is back in the
charismatic movement of the 70s so like
some pentecostal hoo-ha uh we broke away
from the methodist church and so so that
uh
for a bit more uh uh freedom
right uh and so that's so he's that
let's just start a church in our house
and it grew to a high school auditorium
with hundreds of people so
he was a success at everything he
touched but it came at a cost he came at
a cost so he he drove himself to a heart
attack at 50. did you learn from that
did you think these are the things i'm
not going to do i'm not going to put
myself through this yeah yeah well you
know every day i've passed 60 i wake up
going
god bless you here we go this is a
gratitude a gift of another day yeah
that dad didn't have right right what do
you do to
stay healthy to stay
on top of things because because with
the business and all these things going
on and the stress you could easily
crumble we all can i do
but um so what is it you do right well
uh i think you know it's funny i think
the the uh the the lockdowns of the
pandemic in 2020 kind of taught us all
who we were you know some people uh
became
a monster some people
bettered themselves it just you know
some people went yeah went down a spiral
and other others went up
so
i think i i found myself working out
more at what and watching my diet i've
been watching my cholesterol all my life
now since since dad died i started
looking at animal fats and and you know
and uh and whatnot's go and sugars going
oh geez you drink sodas
no i really don't okay don't keep it in
the house don't really do you drink
sodas ryan no
yeah oh
look at the ingredients i've got to i
was just with i was just talking about
this new doctor i got a physical two
days ago yeah and he goes i go is it bad
like if i just have like one soda a day
goes oh yeah yeah not good
no good stop soda well your doctor's
guillermo del toro he is i don't know
who he was i was just throwing that out
there but
i try it's hard but i think that
you know
you know someone like me with neck
problems back problems it's like you
know the more inflammation you put in
your body the more pain you're gonna be
in so if you eliminate the sugar as you
eliminate the [ __ ] you're gonna feel
better right so why doesn't why don't i
just [ __ ] do it right right i think
i'm in and out of doing it maybe take
some turmeric and some cinnamon do you
do that those are all yeah those are all
anti-inflammatories natural ones yeah
really yeah i think i'm allergic to
turmeric are you yeah i think i am isn't
that a shame no there's anything else up
your sleeve there doug
what was the um by the way i didn't know
you were a contortionist well should i
have known that no no one should know
that no uh what does that mean really i
mean because you think contortionist you
think of somebody a circus act yeah
exactly what is a contortion do you
think of someone who can yeah uh well
basically uh i know i i'm not stretched
but i can you know
wow you can blow yourself i can put my
i can put both my legs behind my head
and every guy asks that question so can
you can you blow yourself and if if i
answer yes or no it it yeah it comes
with them
personally it means i tried it means
that yes what's wrong with you but we've
all tried trust me we've all tried have
we succeeded not quite well you're not a
guitarist so you could just put your
your for the most part my legs behind my
head i'm a one trick pony when it comes
to that you know i can also smash down i
found a way to configure myself into
smaller boxes so i did a couple
commercials back in the day i've done
over 100 commercials i started as an
actor in commercials 100 commercials
yeah back yeah and uh so i um a couple
of them involved getting into like we're
going to smash you into a box one was a
an e lee easy fit jeans uh where i got
into a glass box and it was from
standing six foot three into like a
24 by 24 box
uh was kind of
fascinating to watch even when i looked
back and i was like how did i do that
did you like doing it did you like doing
all these things well i did girls like
these
you know i have been with mrs laurie
since college so wow so
thirty so eight years so girl likes
these things yeah yeah see yeah we've
been married first uh we got married in
1984.
84. so you've been married for 16 26 36
30 38 years april 38 years for us yeah
yeah wow yeah that's what old people say
she's seen you in highs and lows haven't
yeah yeah well we met in college when
neither of us had anything had nothing
really going on yeah yeah so that's uh
that's been a blessing for me to to know
i don't have to worry about is is this
person interested in me because of x y
or z right because what the
are they wanting to take advantage of me
with mrs laurie i know we grew together
you know even with the snoring even
especially with the snoring and i'll
tell you why because the happiest sounds
for me
are when she's in the other room
watching tv and laughing
it's like the happiest sound to me
because like i'm not responsible for
anything right now and she's happy she's
she's she's giggling good and when she's
snoring it's also like
life is good for her right now she's
she's at rest she's at peace she's
dreaming about something fantastic uh so
yeah i take mrs laurie's happiness and
her future and her retirement and all
these things are like that was the thing
that concerned me the most in life in my
real life right yeah what was your first
big break because you're doing a lot of
commercials and things but what was the
first thing as a you know as an actor
you felt okay this is
this is this is a cool thing this is a
big thing
uh
but it was in
it was in the tv commercial world uh my
first i would say my fourth tv
commercial booking was the mac tonight
campaign for mcdonald's which turned
into it was a regional uh campaign that
was four four spots running in
california and then it became ooh
national mcdonald's is like
is interested because it was doing sales
figures it was the after 4 pm crowd we
were catering to there's a big crescent
moon head that's saying at a panel when
the clock strikes hey half past six babe
oh so it was a nightclub character
uh and so uh it was so then it went
national right and then it was so
successful nationally that it went
worldwide in other countries so i ended
up working doing 27 commercials as mac
tonight so you made a lot of money a
three year period yeah so a lot of them
already bought my first house with yeah
wow it was from mcdonald's i owe them
that so even though i can't eat there
now my heart right but
yeah with your cholesterol but they have
some menu items you can do i don't want
to
yeah i give a salad what can you eat
let's get a salad mcdonald's yeah some
nuggets wait wait
but what was the what was the big the
movie or the tv show or whatever it was
that was right well well
uh the mac tonight campaign is where
i've started meeting and learning about
the creature affects people in hollywood
land uh and so a lot of a lot of
creature effects people from different
big shops came and worked on on these
different commercial shoots with us you
were interested in that no
i was interested in being a goofy
sidekick on a sitcom that's why i came
to hollywoodland i wanted to put my tall
skinny ostrich neck to work right new
chin right and my new tune uh and so i
did not realize that that this
you know creature effects rubber bits on
on actors was it was really a career
option right i didn't seek it out but
once i had you know
after my first agent had you know
submitted me for all these roles that
were physical tomfoolery and you know
contorting or mime experience needed
because they need a movement blah blah
blah those rules often came with a look
that was glued on to you right so that's
how i started meeting creature affects
people and then that reputation and they
would go spread my name around their own
community and then come i would get
phone calls at home sidestepping agents
and casting directors hey doug we're at
the shop we're working on this alien
character but you want to come in for a
quick fitting to see if it's going to be
good for you so i would and then once it
was a good fit then then every all the
business people would get involved and
it would become a booking
so uh so kind of so my career kind of so
people liked you people like you doug
jones well no i don't want to boast i
just saw you in arkansas at a convention
and the first thing we just have a big
hug and a kiss and just you know just
friendly and and you're just that guy
you're that guy and it sounds to me like
you've always been that guy and that's
why how your career started by being a
good guy easy to work with and being
talented at the same time that's all
it's all very important uh
being good at what you do is one thing
uh being nice while you're doing it is
quite another you know right and not
every not every actor gets that
unfortunately you were never an [ __ ]
never an [ __ ] phase well you know i i
you would have to ask other people i
don't think so right i don't i don't
think so did you we'll get into it
because i do want to ask you some
questions because you're very honest
you're very open so what was the first
kind of big gig that you remember well
then okay so outside of tv commercials
um uh you could when you're a young
actor when you get a booking and you
you're like oh gosh i'm gonna do this
movie you think this is my big break
before you know how it's gonna do all
the great and we all and then you learn
and then you right then you think like
this is gonna be huge it's gonna i'm
gonna be the first name on the
marquee but you know my my first movie
movie that i remember really being like
notable to mention was was a
night angel it was a horror film
yeah
it played in uh it played in theaters
for a week and then instrument theaters
and then it went to the vhs right oh it
was back in 1989
i think it was my one or may night maybe
it might have come out now did you play
a creature in this no i was a guy i was
a good you were just an actor i was i
was the guy who
i played the character that i came to
hollywood to be which was the goofy
sidekick at a a high fashion magazine i
was like well like an office helper guy
right wearing a baseball cap with my
curly hair and that's before my chin by
the way 19 1980 nothing
and uh and i was just like the goofy guy
that like you know hey i'm best friend
of the handsome lead man of the movie
and when the devil lady comes to take
his soul she kind of uses me to get to
him and uh so
yeah anyway i thought oh i'm i'm killing
it this is going to be great well the
movie record you know again after a week
in the theater nobody even heard of
night angel right right so
that's when i realized oh this is going
to be a longer road than i thought uh
so really i did i kind of worked
consistently for many years from 19 uh
uh gosh
80
okay i started in
86 i'm gonna say
yeah 86 is when i start
booking my first commercials and then i
got my you know a guest a guest role
here or there on a tv show being sitcom
this uh one hour drama that but no real
lulls
no real down like months and months or a
year without work no no i've had i've
had
a month a month or two of lowell going
am i ever going to work again every
actor goes through that am i ever going
to work again as a phrase we've all said
many times
but
uh but but overall looking back
hindsight is everything it's like no you
know i've uh consistently been pretty
consistent over the years uh so um
really at least my my sag pension plan
says so right but um uh but uh uh other
than that um
uh where were we well the transition i
guess because this was your first big
acting role and then it went in the
theaters and then went to so
how did you trans what's the word how
did you uh transition into did somebody
see you and go oh he'd be great as a as
this creature or he'd be great as how
did that start
uh
right
that would have been like like i said
from the commercial world
than
monster a or b in
movie
this or that uh so i think yeah gosh
what was it called a dark tower
was a movie with
michael um
landon no
michael
well you guess what jenny agatha was the
star she's gonna look it up jenny agatha
was the the lead actress in it and uh
her husband in the movie died fell into
a cement uh while it was wet and built
while a skyscraper was going up
and uh his soul came out and and haunted
her when the building was near
completion because she pushed him
into the cement or years before it all
comes out in the story uh who the
director no the the the lead uh the
actor that i that i michael moriarty
moriarty i was gonna say that
michael i i played the dead version of
him
his ghostly figure that came to haunt
jenny agatha for killing me right and um
so so that was my first movie movie that
i was it was that was like i think
um what was it called dark tower came
before night angel actually
um and did you have to wear prosthetics
for this i did i because i because i was
like you know a haggard ghostly sunken
version of michael moriarty basically
you want to see it there's a picture oh
is there really let me see that that's
me how did you find that because
the weber net is amazing right yeah now
how was that that was that looks like
that was probably your first real big
prosthetic piece right for a movie
i've done them for commercials before
that yeah so but how'd that feel going
into that did you feel
do you how many hours did that take no
it just takes out it almost takes hours
and and hours yeah yeah yeah and you
just because you you know what do you do
during that time
read
no no you can't you listen to music
music yes uh tell stories with your
makeup artist they become your best
friends they always agree with them all
day always too it's like it's like being
in a barber's chair or or being at a uh
your bartender right yeah
that's so true they're your therapist
they're therapists yeah they are yeah
so uh there's all that i might even if
it's if i'm in a chair and they're just
working on my front side i can maybe
doze off maybe if they tilt me back a
little bit uh you like dozing off oh i
do especially with you know if you have
a 3am call time for a long makeup job
and yeah you'll i i do many jobs sleep
deprived so right that's part of the
deal and makeups can be anywhere from
two hours like on star trek discovery
they've got these pre-made pre-painted
uh prosthetic pieces that get glued onto
me and blended in saru
yeah and so it's two hours in that yeah
that's bad the human characters on star
trek are in as much makeup
much time in the makeup in here
trailers as i am
so uh so it's not so bad but then you
you know if you're doing a head to toe
creature like like abe sapien from the
first hellboy movie uh they got it it
was seven hours a day they got it down
to five hours a day for hellboy to the
golden army so down to five hours a day
is it a daunting thing to go to bed at
night and go i have to wake up and be
seven hours and make up oh yeah yeah
yeah do you get anxiety the word tell me
about that
[Music]
yeah no i wouldn't say anxiety but i do
i i have spent mo a lot of my career
dreading going to work you know just
because it's like oh i gotta go through
this even though even if it's a project
i love and i and that's the end if the
end result is a product we'll be proud
of then i can go through the hell that
it takes to make it because i did come
up with a catch phrase
a few years ago i'm very proud of it's
called and it is uh
pain is temporary film is forever
told temporary film is for and that's so
true that has been my matter how you're
feeling this is going to be forever so
your best okay
that's yeah so that's where i've been
wow yep
you have to think though
all those hours in the makeup trailer
you get a little upset a little unnerved
a little irritable a little bit
seriously no no no you're you're you're
just you're just a different specimen
different a different kind of human well
i don't get antsy i'm not i'm not
somebody who when i'm sitting still i
don't have to fill that space with doing
something you know how many people are
like what do we think we should do i'm
like i'm fine just sitting here i am a
boring human being really i can stare at
a wall and drool and be completely
content so that makes that translates
into the makeup trailer really really
well do you have any uh issues with
certain prosthetics certain things that
you wore that give you that you
developed a neck problem or or
a foot problem or whatever kind of
problem no no i never uh nothing no no i
mean like
yeah i mean
especially the more the more mechanical
type if you're wearing a big head that
has um
you know uh motors and things in it that
are
uh that are
the servos and things like batteries and
motors and things that are operating a
puppeteered face uh that's more of a
more of still part of a suit it slips on
you they buckle it in or they velcro it
or they glue it down
but it's not really a makeup
when you're in something like that that
can be heavy and can push on places and
you come away with red marks yeah but
what's the heaviest thing you've ever
worn the heaviest amphibian no no no uh
the adventures of galgameth it was a
movie that ended up on the disney
channel back in the um
mid 90s
i filmed it in 1995
and i i played a
a kind of a god a kind and gentle
helpful godzilla-like character it's
kind of a lizard guy who grew from like
uh three feet tall all the way to 50
feet tall throughout the movie so i was
i
um a little person named felix
scilla
he was um felix silla was
cousin it is that that the hairy thing
in adam's family the tv series way back
in the day oh wow um and he he passed
away recently bless his soul uh he
uh was he was little galgi so he he did
galgameth from from spoon size all the
way up to three something feet tall and
then when he grew to six feet something
that's when i took over the roll and all
the way to 50 feet so
uh that's that was heavy that suit was
100 pounds i weigh
135 pounds so so
when you're adding 100 pounds to a
skinny guy like me that was that was
just
hellacious together how long could you
and you had to walk around with 100
pounds on you well walk around emote act
you know be intimidating be swiping how
much time did they have before you're
like i can't do this yeah we we would we
would yeah i the head came off often you
know uh during throughout the day and it
could it wasn't glued on onto me so that
was another suit not makeup right uh and
so that would be
yeah that would be the most hilacious
thing ever have you worked with
directors who just you could tell aren't
they they're not respecting you
oh yeah i mean like you're just like
they're just bossing you around and
telling you what to do like move over we
could see this make sure you do this
yeah like where you're like [ __ ] you but
doug jones wouldn't say that i would and
that's why
i'm not uh anyway
um but you've had those moments and the
actor has uh you know you know
working with the director is like
is like dating you know you you find the
right the right click that fits and
you're like oh that's really good
guillermo de turos is
when you have a you know that symbiotic
relationship this is working you know we
understand each other there's a
shorthand we don't have to say many
words is that what that was working with
guillermo oh yeah yeah yeah he uh
he gives
he'll give me notes ahead of time before
we start filming
months weeks ahead
and uh and then he he really is he
respects an actor you want he wants you
to bring your own thing to it he he
he he cast you in a movie because of
what you have to bring so he doesn't
want to he doesn't want to spoil the
suit by adding too much of his own spice
to it you know
that's a great director and so when went
on went on set like for instance uh
let's go back to
hellboy hellboy to the golden army were
filming right there was a whole sequence
that he was going to do a tracking shot
around me uh that was
um just he wasn't going to cut away to
anything so he hadn't it was going to it
was a one-shot scene quickly with me
doing things with props putting a
contact lens in spritzing my my gills
with things and i was a fish man in that
movie right uh so
uh so as the as the camera was tr it was
on a circular track going around me
and he wasn't going to get any coverage
on this to cut away to something else so
he had to get all of this action done in
a certain amount of time
so i was
so take one i'm going through all of the
beats that we had rehearsed
and
he is at the end of take one he says cut
doggy you're boring me to tears that's
all i had to say and i knew exactly how
to fix it really yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because once you know each other
they're boring to tears you're right
right in the shape of water uh another
fish man character i played for him um
uh he might stop me at some point go cut
dougie
a noise and i was like got it and i knew
what to do the next time what does that
mean well because we had talked about uh
the difference between those these two
fish men that i've played for him
one is very intelligent refined
gentlemanly uh
and the other one is an animal from the
wild right big difference right so so he
would remind me you're an animal i don't
want to see any guy any human i want to
see the animal side of you so so if he
saw
a human reaction or gesture from me as
the amphibian man in the shape of water
he would just go doggy
just to remind me animal
right so yeah you develop a shorthand
was there ever a moment where he just
was so astonished by you and what you
had done and brought to it that you you
did something that
non-verbally right that he was like
doggy what like he was so happy
does he get that way does he get kind of
animated and happy yeah he totally does
oh when he like he's he's he is such a
a grown-up kid i love him i knew that i
met i noticed that about him the first
time i met him on mimik many years ago
in 1997.
he's a he's a big kid and i think that's
why he's such a great director and why
audiences love him is because he
he makes things that'll make the kid in
him go
you get excited yeah that's what he
makes he makes things that will he'll
that will give himself a geek gasm
therefore we all get one when we watch
his work yeah but um uh
yeah no uh pan's labyrinth uh what a
character that was too terrifying two
you played two i was the fawn and pale
man in the film right
and uh when i was playing the fawn
i think it was uh he came and kissed my
forehead after a take uh i'll never
forget it because because well there
were so many notes on that one um
because
i i was playing a character that the
fawn was part man part goat part tree he
was like a comedy he was like a you know
this fantastical
you know fantasy character so
uh so and i was aging backwards when you
meet me in the movie i'm more old and
decrepit and i get younger every time
you see me right until the very end so
that we were filming that first
introduction scene and i was old and
creepy and kind of
uh so for some reason that first the
after the first take and what i brought
to it uh
uh he just came over and kissed me on
the forehead and said that's it that's
all my those are my notes
really
it does not feel good so good so good
yeah yeah well he told me he told me on
pan's labyrinth after after we filmed
for the first two weeks he came over to
me one uh i was sitting in this weird
chair i had a tail sticking out of my
butt so i kind of had to
i had like a bicycle seat with a t-bar
that was padded that i could it was very
uncomfortable between takes on that on
that particular movie
uh i had there was no way to really
recline and i had in the head we had
mechanics built into it with these long
huge horns
very heavy so my little skinny neck was
like oh my gosh
but
i'm sitting in that chair kind of like
taking a breather between shot setups
and he came shuffling over to me put his
hand on my form and said dougie i know
you have not heard much from me on this
uh so far but uh it's because you're
getting it right
i'm like okay well i'll i'll take that
thank you
wow and i did know that yeah les is
you know when you're not getting so much
direction from him he's it's him not
wanting to ruin things now you had a lot
of roles or some roles where you would
go in and learn tons of dialogue there
was one where you had to learn a ton of
spanish mm-hmm what was that no that was
pan's labyrinth that was pan's like the
fawn spoke spanish so you he spoke
spanish so you learned a great deal of
spanish all the exposition came from the
fawn he had explained a little ophelia
who she was where she came from where
she needs to go how to save the
underworld all that came from me in
spanish in paragraph form it was like oh
my god and then they cut it
well no they didn't they replaced your
voice as i asked yeah right now you
asked i would never ask to have my voice
replaced but uh but in spanish why not
uh because
i told him
i think he got the wrong guy for this
movie because i don't i don't speak
spanish and surely there's a spanish
actor who can pull this off way better
no no
he told me that you can count to 10 for
all i care uh but you got to play the
phone because he had in mind what he
need he wrote the role with me in mind
he knew what he wanted so
were you terrified
i've never been more terrified of
anything in my life than that
particularly how long did it take you to
learn all the dialogue months months
because you're learning spanish spanish
right and it was uh so can you speak any
of it now do you remember any of it
that's the line i remember pretty cool
pretty good thank you sounds great so i
uh so he gave me the option to just like
you know like give the right count to 10
like he said but i knew
i couldn't give him uh lip movement
going one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10.
and then try to dub over that with lips
not matching that would have been ugly
and then also you're playing i was
playing opposite a an eleven-year-old
actress who
needed something more from me than one
through ten right
right you know what i'm saying yes of
course i mean i would have been a
disservice to her into the scene to
the scenes
to uh count was he very grateful that
you did all that
i i believe so i um
i just i showed up knowing it all so
thank heaven but i will say
as hard as it was to memorize dialogue
in a language you don't speak
once you do know it it comes out of you
the same every time because in english
when you're memorizing english dialogue
your native tongue you have a vocabulary
full of options right right so uh you
know like this uh
oh what would uh adjectives and adverbs
are where we get i get hung up on like
when things will come out because i have
so many options to pull from right which
was it again uh uh uh but in spanish uh
or i also did a movie in french the same
way i played a creature uh
version of of serge gainsbourg
as his alter ego and that and friend
same thing i once once it's in there
it's in there that one way and you have
no options so it comes out the same
every time so thank heaven for that just
took it just took a minute to get it in
there but you had experience was it was
it um surfer the uh silver surfer was
that the one where they took out your
dialogue
it's happened twice in english
out of my 36 year career i've been
dubbed over in english twice and the uh
the unfortunate uh misconception is that
doug always gets voice over because it
happened
twice and that's the thought the rest of
my career has been my voice uh and you
also put it into a contract it's now a
part of my contracts right i will not i
will not be voiced over you got some
clout in the industry you got some
respect maybe not or they might say f
you doug and then i don't do the job so
that's fine has that ever happened no no
ben kevin
kevin but but um
i uh i
uh
uh
i lost my trained hot again well about
uh this happens a lot this happened at
my age this happens you're not even old
oh but i lose my train of thought all
the time yeah but i was saying about the
lines being debits in your contract
right that's it okay dubbed over right i
it happened on hellboy one
uh and that was again i was not i was
not sp even a spec on the celebrity
radar at that time and this is 2003. so
you couldn't really say much been
working consistently but i but nobody i
did not have household name recognition
at all right so uh david hyde pierce did
he was at the top of his frasier game
that was in their final season
and he also had a very distinctive sound
in his voice
and uh so
did it break your heart yes that
actually broke my heart but i went into
that job i went into hellboy knowing
that they had a pre-discussion with the
studio and guillermo del toro
uh he was the direct director of that as
well
uh he told me uh when i came in to
discuss abe sapien with him
uh he told me that day they're talking
about doing a celebrity voiceover just
so you know and i said oh gosh i would
really rather you not do that
and he said well i'll i'll campaign for
you if i uh but but this is what this is
what the studio has to do and i
understand this is a marketing thing and
that's above my pay grade i don't know
how whatever so uh attaching a bigger
name to a role for marquee status or
poster status great i get i totally
understand but doesn't mean i like it
yeah and when i when i finished the role
uh having delivered a voice that i was
satisfied with for abe sapien and that
guillermo was satisfied with for abe
sapien
and everybody else was too i did get a
phone call two weeks after i went in for
my adr voice looping session to clean up
my dialogue which in that day went
really really well i'm like okay i think
this is going to stay mine
two weeks later i got a phone call from
guillermo saying uh they
we were voicing it over with david hyde
pierce i was crushed i i i'm not gonna i
tear did run down my cheek on the phone
with him but
uh but he he i i asked him is it was it
a performance issue you know is it does
it need to be replaced he goes nope it
was not it was you everyone loved what
you did but david's got a name and a
distinctive sound that that like they're
they're hoping to sell
and is that when you sort of went
home and talked to laurie and said
i'm not going to allow them to do this
again i couldn't come out and play
anymore uh no yeah it happened because
silver surfer came after that that came
after so that was that was the final
final right because i did not have the
same the same heads up
on the silver surfer
but but let me let me back up for a
second i do want to finish up to say
that david hyde pierce was quite a
gentleman in this whole process he came
in to do his adr voice looping session
to dub over me
he heard me in his earpiece my original
sound and and my my my cleanup that i
did in in my adr session
and he said what am i doing here which
was very kind of him right and so he he
finished the job he was hired to do and
i thought he did a great job he was
great i love him dearly but uh but then
when the movie came out his name is not
in the credits it's on imdb but it is
not in the credits of the movie and he
did no press didn't come to the red
carpet premiere nothing and when asked
why he said it's out of respect to doug
jones do actors do this for each other i
almost just cried right now that just
almost hit me like that's like the
sweetest thing ever right what yeah i've
never met him in person when i do he's
getting a kiss right here yeah because i
said out of respect to doug jones i'm
not
allowing myself to be credited in this
movie you loved you i mean do you
believe that right
he said it he said it's amazing no it's
amazing so i i i i adore him damn he
didn't have to do that i i wouldn't i i
i would have been fine had he taken the
credit for what he the work that he did
sure
uh so anyway but then
and guillermo del toro also told me on
that same phone call that if we do a
hellboy 2 that i'll be using your voice
for that and he did come through on that
promise that's right i also did the the
um
the voice for abe sapien in the two
animated films that came between hellboy
one and two
so uh so
and the video game so
my voice is out there so you're doing
just fine
things worked out worked out fine do you
consider your career to be someone uh
similar
not dissimilar to andy circus
in a way that right such a great actor
he is and he's done a lot of these roles
that people are like wait that's him
that's him yeah and then you know
have you ever met him yeah
we finally met at san diego comic-con at
an after-party one
he was talking to somebody i was like oh
my gosh i went over and tapped him on
the shoulder and i said andy doug jones
he goes oh threw his arms out and we
both hugged each other for about five
minutes just giggling and then parting
looking each other and then hugging
again yeah it was uh it was awesome it
was lovely and uh yeah we hung out for
the rest of the evening and it was just
uh
and we agreed on something that we both
uh
are have have
similar uh um
a similar image in the in the movie
industry but his makeup goes on after
the fact that mine goes on before but
you know that's the only difference
really right
that's amazing
yeah because he does a lot of like
motion capture digital yeah i know
exactly
right performance for the audience who
may not understand what we're talking
about right i knew you got it yeah i was
just taking it in yeah
thank you this is called [ __ ] talking
with doug jones
these are questions rapid fire if you
like oh dear sakes uh from my lovely
patrons hi patrons oh they support the
podcast in many ways and i love you guys
go to patreon.com inside of you to
support the podcast more keep us afloat
uh here they are
haunted john
uh
what was a good memory from hocus pocus
and how is it like to work with bett
i've been a big fan of bette midler's
before the movie filmed she was on a hot
streak at that in the 90s there with
outrageous fortune and and uh down and
out in beverly hills and big business
and one movie after no one hit after
another and her huge recording career
i'm on my way to work my first day on
hocus pocus and what do i hear on the
radio from a distance
one of her huge hits
i work with her that night
she was delightful and goofy and uh and
uh hilarious and she had those buck
teeth in his winifred and no eyebrows
and so it was hard to keep the giggles
from coming while looking at her that
close
and she was so so sweet and then on the
way home on the car radio i heard uh you
are the wind beneath my wings like she's
huge
yeah so it was lovely uh and then
reconnecting with her recently i just
did hocus pocus 2 which is coming out
hocus pocus 2. coming out on disney did
you just play the same character i did
billy i reprise billy butchers
butcherson
and so the four of us immortals from the
first movie are the ones that came back
for hocus pocus what a true bunch of new
kids 29 years later i don't know how
many sequels get made 29 years after the
first
but to have all four of us back and
looking almost exactly the same as we
did almost 30 years ago holy [ __ ] yeah
the the ladies all looked fantastic
uh and um
and i i looked ex i looked like like
seconds had passed
because um
in 29 years because i was wearing a
prosthetic you know yeah and you didn't
get fat
with exactly the same weight exactly the
same build as i was 29 years ago so it
looked
freakishly the same and it was the same
wig from the first movie that was the
wig had been sitting on number the on
display at someone's creature shop and
they just took it off and put it back on
me and exactly this and the fit pro it
didn't shrink nothing nothing
everything's the same
leanne p of all the characters you
played which one do you identify with
the most oh right
uh uh
there are parts of me and all of them
you know different parts like uh the
silver surfer i loved his quiet stoic
heroic thing those are things that i am
not but i want to be i want to have the
confidence that i don't have to flap my
hands around when i talk like the silver
server didn't need to he just he's just
spoke
um uh but but i think that um
um
the the the the intelligent characters
that are very gentlemanly i i like to
identify with like like abe sapien and
saroo from star trek discovery very
intelligent very gentlemanly they could
also they could also pass as a butler
with their behavior is star trek the
hardest dialogue you've ever had to
learn yes without question uh when
you're doing paragraphs of science
fiction dialogue with terminology that
is not in common day use and how long do
you have to learn it oh you know you
know when your scripts come out all day
you know what series television is like
you
sometimes it has been a couple days now
in more recent seasons uh season one was
like that we would get rewrites at the
last minute going what
that's a paragraph i've never seen
before you learn dialogue quickly no i'm
a slow learner
so what do they do i mean what i mean
you just learn it somehow yeah just kind
of you get fear will
drive you forward if you use it
correctly i think i don't know i don't
know i don't know wow it take but
there's there's a lot of outtakes too
yeah a lot of fun stuff oh yeah right
you know slammed a character into death
maya p what's the most challenging role
you've played
most challenging right maybe physically
maybe mentally maybe both right right
right well let's go back to uh uh those
characters in foreign languages the fawn
from pan's labyrinth and uh and legule
from gainsborg a heroic life the french
movie
um i'm playing fantastical heavy
five-hour makeup applications with
paragraphs of dialogue in a language i
don't speak so that's mentally
physically emotionally and then having
to you know
play
an arc of emotion you know and and
character development and relationship
status with someone else in the movie
whatever it is that's that's a lot to
take on yeah so those would be the
challenges have fun was what we do in
the shadows what were we doing with his
by the way i didn't know it was you and
then i saw and i go
but you were terrific i think i texted
you or emailed you i was like you did
you are phenomenal did you see it what
we do in the shadows yeah of course the
series yeah he did an episode and it was
j it blew me over actually i've done
several episodes now uh between i don't
know how far you've caught up oh no i
have i only saw the one that you had
okay
look at him look at look at that well
just keep it off for a minute for god
sakes we're almost done here
so
um
uh uh yeah no
season one and season three and i just
did an episode reviews before the so uh
that'll be coming back uh as the baron
baron
what a great character uh he's kind of
like a play on nosferatu i think he's
kind of like old world uh he's the old
world uh uh vampire that is coming to
check on these doofus kids and that that
i sent to conquer the new world north
america and they've never made it out of
staten island so uh so to th the the
show is so absurd and so lovely
i have i have such a great time on it i
would you go to work and you laugh all
day
and everyone on the show do they let you
improvise at all they encourage it yeah
yeah you'll do a scripted take or two
and then they say here's the fun one and
they they oh and the series regulars
know what to do with that too they go
all over the place did they let did you
do you remember saying anything just off
the cuff and it was it was in the show
oh uh uh from
because my one big episode in season one
was the barons night out where the
entire episode was all about me uh yep
and
i don't remember much i was terrified of
that because it was so i was doing star
trek at the same time and i had they had
to borrow me for a couple days so i was
like i was
exhausted
yeah
i did have an improv moment in the in
the
most recent one that i just filmed that
will i have yet to see if they're going
to keep it but i but funny stuff i i
winked at myself going doug that was
pretty good yeah and they liked it
people were like oh yeah yeah i got a
chuckle from the crew yeah so
uh
last question what was it like uh
playing one of the gentlemen in my
opinion one of the best episodes of
buffy the vampire slayer buffy the
vampire slayer yes i was the lead
gentleman uh in that and you keep
anything from sets ever
yeah uh uh
boy i wish i'd started that a long time
ago before i knew that the the secondary
market that was out there
to sign and sell these things yeah uh
but no i
i've kept some prosthetic piece face
pieces like if when they remove it from
me i'll maybe take it home in a plastic
bag i have a few of those but they're
not on display anywhere i'm really bad
at that you should do it i know i've got
a pile in the corner my house i know i
know it's great this is great it's a
museum i know i'm single i need
pretty much i need to do this to a room
but you like doing buffy it was fun i
did it was fun and it was uh the hush
episode
has been a fan favorite over the years
that and the musical episode for the
buffy fans out there uh are the two that
i hear the most about so i'm really
tickled pink and to be a guest star on
one episode of a show and then have it
live this long after that was 1999
and so here we are you know 20 some
years later and people are still talking
about it and
so that that that means the world to me
and was directed that episode you know
as tv episodes go every
uh every episode is directed by someone
different so
that episode was directed by joss whedon
himself the creator of the show he wrote
the script he directed it so we knew it
was special for him to come out of the
office and and put his hands on into
that one right
and so to to take the
verbal dialogue away again i i stole
everyone's voice in sunnyvale for that
episode and uh and did our dastardly
deeds in the quiet and when we heard a
human voice that's when our heads
exploded at the end of this episode so
that was daring and innovative
television and again visual storytelling
without verbal dialogue it was an
exercise in that too where do you see
yourself like uh you're 60 right i'm 61.
oh god i'll be 62 in may chuck yeah
where do you think do you do you want to
retire ever do you think you know when i
hit 65 i'm done 70 i'm done yeah when do
you think you've had enough like i just
i've had enough
or would you always be open to something
if it came along i'm always going to be
open to something i i i want to betty
white this if i can really yeah i mean
if i if i can be 99.9 and still working
uh like she did i would be uh tickle
pink with that
but
the rubber bits and the glue and the
mechanic that will stop that that needs
to phase out at some point i'm i'm being
far more picky with those roles now uh
so you might have a couple years left of
that i think maybe so i have to get him
while he can yeah i'm gonna finish out
my star trek uh uh contract uh for
however many seasons we're going and uh
and then we will see we'll see from
there but i really do want to explore
more
human characters exactly and um and as
you should and i've played several over
the years that just you know but you
know those are less memorable and people
don't you know well when you play a role
in shape of water and you went to the
oscars right you did yeah yeah it was a
great god wouldn't it bro didn't they
win best picture you did jesus man best
picture with a monster on the cover is
was on you and that's you it's unusual
yeah see you should have that poster up
in your house i should i should i should
you should frame it a beautiful frame
and just have that that's me this is
okay yeah seriously
they got the wrong creature in that
movie that movie doesn't win an oscar
you i mean that was just you're acting
in that it's just super blessed it
really is uh you're a superb human being
you as are you michael i love having you
here today i adore you and i guess i'm
not so scared after all i said it worked
out okay this is easy okay it's ryan you
should be nervous about right that
mustache right that's like keith
hernandez from the mets that's awesome
yeah uh thank you i love you i love you
more i hope you come back
let's do it let's do it okay bye
thank you doug jones uh wonderful
interview i loved having him on he's so
gracious he's so sweet and uh i love his
story
and uh very few people work as hard as
doug jones that's true i'll tell you
that yeah he uh
that is a it's a very specific and very
enduring talent yeah it is super super
such an actor endurance and i saw him in
what we do in the shadows the series and
uh i think we talked about that and he
was just genius like wait a minute it
said doug jones that was doug
he was brilliant that's so exciting
thank you doug
um
also just want to uh throw out another
um mention to the animal rescue mission
that rehabs and finds forever homes and
for abuse and neglected animals go to
www.theanimalrescuemission.org
and donate
also
don't forget to follow us um on the
podcast the handles are at insidee
podcast on instagram and facebook and
insideapod on twitter um you could watch
on youtube and please subscribe and
write a review if you like the podcast
that's all that's all i'm asking
um
and you can listen to the intro and it
tells you where i'm gonna be
for i'm gonna be in raleigh um this
weekend i'm gonna be in boston august
12th weekend with tom signing autographs
uh also the inside of you online store
go there for some cool stuff patreon
join patreon we're about to do one of
the the perks of being a patreon is the
top tier patreons get shout outs on the
podcast which i'm about to
shout out all these glorious people who
really help the podcast and keep it
afloat
and uh it means the world to me that you
guys uh give to the podcast um it's a
little the little podcast that could is
that what i call it
and it keeps going and i appreciate ryan
still being here with me
we try to have a good time every week we
have a good time we do we do we have a
good time we both deal with anxiety and
we both
you know we're living life and uh having
a great time what do you mean this is
super
awesome uh but uh anyway i love you all
um and thank you patrons here's a shout
out to all the patrons and uh here we go
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa ukico
jill e brian h nico p robert b jason w
kristen k raj c joshua d cjp jennifer
and stacey l jamal f janelle b kimberly
mike uh e correct yeah eldon soprano 99
more ramirez santiago m chad w leanne p
maya p
maddie s belinda and correct chris h
dave h sheila g brad d ray h correct tab
of the t tom and suzanne b liliana a
talia m betsy d chat l mary and meg
correct med k
dan and big stevie w angel and rihanna
and c corey k dev next and michelle a
jeremy c andy t gavinator david
h c c yeah it was a tough damn john b
brandy d yvore camille s the c joey m
design
m-o-t-g correct eugene and
uh leah correct chris p nikki g
corey kdp nicole patricia heather l jake
b james b megan t
mel s orlando c caroline r rob e paul c
christine s sarah s eric h jennifer r
shane r emma r
mark m jeremy v andrew m robert g
zadochi 77 did i say that right
zedoji andreas n alexandra chris r
michael f samantha w and michelle
d i couldn't do it without all you guys
thank you for supporting the podcast
thank you for being a lovely patron i'll
be on one of those youtube lives soon
and i think i'm doing a thing with the
top tier patrons i'm going to do a zoom
for the top tier patrons we're going to
all zoom together um
i think it might be
it might be tomorrow look on the patron
thing and uh hopefully it'll be there
but uh look from uh myself here michael
rosenbaum in the hollywood hills of
california
hello i'm ryan as well in the hollywood
hills california that's right
and we always have a nice time here we
appreciate you uh hanging with us this
is uh this is always great and
i feel like my mood is better today
yeah i feel like i have my you know i'm
getting back to my old self and uh
uh thank you everyone for all the
support and love and people checking in
on me and all that jazz and uh follow me
on instagram at the michael rosenbaum
follow ryan
tay is ryan that tears ryan i'll post
every couple of months yeah he'll do it
but you know follow him anyway we love
you thank you for the support a little
wave to the camera
and uh be good to yourself please be
good to yourself and until next week
i'll be i'll be waiting for you
[Music]